[Musik]
schweizer in los angeles für präsentiert
das stück heimat egal wo sie sind
[Musik]
ja
da sein
[Musik]
es ist das erste mal dass ich in den
vereinigten staaten bin
es ist ein bisschen wie im film überall
ist ständig musik auch die werbung ist
lustig zb werbung für anwaltskanzleien
völlig anders als in der schweiz
hier machen sie werbung mit dem mut
jetzt sitze ich im ober richtung campus
es ist etwas stressig wie jedes mal zu
semesterbeginn man fragt sich ob man
freunde finden wird ob man richtig
angezogen ist der eigene stil ankommt
die uci ist dorian steuern die
internationale beziehungen in genf
studiert geht für ein semester an die
renommierte university of california
[Musik]
die erste knacknuss im campus labyrinth
ihr zimmer zu finden
ich weiß nicht recht wo ich hingehen
soll vielleicht doch dort drüben
ich versuche es hier
mit geschlossen
ich habe die id aber den zimmerschlüssel
noch nicht da ist es wir sind hier das
ist das stadion
da ist es erster stock zimmer 123
danke
[Musik]
wir sind auf der küstenstraße nach santa
monica fahren in nördliche richtung nach
mali zwischen malibu und santa monica in
pacific palisades
[Musik]
mein kunde richard goldsmith ist
produzent und präsident einer
französischen firma die fernsehserien
für kinder empfiehlt ein riese mit
weichem herz das ist trend
er kam vor 28 jahren aus liebe zum
american football aus lugano in die usa
dann versuchte er sein glück beim fehlen
seiner zweiten großen leidenschaft was
ein kurzes zwischenspiel wurde der
branche bliebe zwar treu wechselte dann
aber in die zweite reihe hinter die
stars meine arbeit ist nicht immer die
gleiche manchmal fahre ich bin
privatchauffeur manchmal bin ich mit
einer hollywood größe unterwegs und
arbeite als bodyguard
schön dich zu sehen
was einen guten bodyguard ausmacht du
musst gut gebaut sein so wie ich zwei
meter groß breite schultern
[Musik]
hast du viel zu tun
die oscars für mails dienen den typ von
disney war sich nicht sicher wollte mir
noch bescheid geben aber wahrscheinlich
geht er ist ja zwei filme im rennen die
unglaublichen 2 und ralf reicht was
gehst du an die grammys
[Musik]
frühaufsteher in dora umgeht den
höllischen morgenverkehr in der stadt
der engel
sie träumt von einem funktionierenden ev
ich fürchte verstand das st
doch sehr wenig zielführend
sie hatte wahnsinnige fünf stunden und
es ist komplizierte produkte suchen im
internet
die schlag für den landwirt josef wenn
es hinten ins mittelfeld ab aber im
augen eine vereinsamte spitze
für das ich eigentlich ganz und drummer
und so was er denn das ist gut möglich
wieder mit den ganzen kreieren
er breitet sich aus wie ein krake seine
tentakel kein stadtkern nur quartiere
und regionen über den fahnen aus aller
herren länder wem die stadt samt
akklamation ist riesig 20 millionen
menschen leben ja abenteuer in der
metropole die sich zwischen ozean und
gebirgsketten ergießt
im herzen des häuser meeres liegt
hollywood sehnsuchtsort für stars und
sternchen die traumfabrik lockt wer sich
auf sie einlässt gewinnt oder geht unter
ob schäbig oder schillernd um show oder
schicht in los angeles kann es jede und
jeder zu etwas bringen
in der regel kommen die 4400
schweizerinnen und schweizer die hier
leben ganz gut klar
endlich ein herzliches willkommen von
kämmerin eine der beiden zimmergenossen
das sind pflanzen die mir meine freunde
überlassen haben schön ich liebe
pflanzen und falls du noch keinen bezug
hast kannst du erst mal das hirn später
15 quadratmeter zu dritt das bad auf dem
flur in l wird man erfinderisch
ich weiß nicht welcher schrank meine ist
ich denke
das zimmer habe ich mir kleiner
vorgestellt das ist schon mal eine gute
überraschung
ich habe nicht damit gerechnet einen
eigenen schreibtisch zu haben
ich fühle mich wohl meine zimmergenossin
ist super sympathisch sie hat mir zwei
drei dinge erklärt den pelikanen zu
sehen und gleichzeitig pläne entwerfen
niemand hätte auf rossi ist raum gesetzt
und doch hat er 50 jährige gebürtige
bündner die zweifler in seinem umfeld
lügen gestraft in los angeles hatte er
sein fundament gelegt ausbildung machen
wie trikot hat das masters der krieg
machte architektur und haben eigentlich
noch ein video welle zugespitzt und das
haben wir nicht gemacht
live gibt es ja wissen denn am schluss
bestimmen oder in schwarz weiß jörg
singer nach 2 20
am anfang habe ich einfach ganz knapp
die rechnung aufgegangen aber eigentlich
nicht folgt leben am schluss grund an in
venice beach im nebel hat für 500 dollar
an ist ca
im monat mehr autos gestohlen
in retrospective blogs ist eine geburt
ist auch gesehen vielleicht im moment
nicht aber du lernst du lernst mannes in
los angeles also lernt account und und
chips finden
man darf nicht jedes schweizer büro oder
moleküle meine staatskritischen
neighbours der universität bonn will ich
nicht der normale architektur werdegang
gemacht haben die schweiz macht mit eth
und saucen und ich habe einen anderen
werdegang gemacht und ja es ist krieg
und denn denn das dort begrüßen lüth
löst das bios dass du denn hier streicht
in der lukas baby safe dass gott
[Musik]
ich kam 1995 nach los angeles
ich habe einen master an der uci ll
gemacht ich bin mit einem one-way-ticket
ihr angekommen
da gab es einen professoren streik sie
kämpften für einen besseren lohn und
eine krankenversicherung stellt ja dass
man vor lehrkräfte die keine
krankenversicherung haben
es war ein ziemlicher schock als ich
jahren kann ich habe die stadt überhaupt
nicht verstanden werden da gab es kein
zentrum ich wusste nicht wohin um leute
zu treffen einen kaffee zu trinken
ich wusste gar nichts schritt für
schritt habe ich mich in dieser stadt
eingelebt die trotz allem schwierig
bleibt
[Musik]
dann habe ich mich in sie verliebt ich
glaube weil sie so schwer zu erobern war
habe ich dann ja zu ihr gesagt
in ihrem atelier im industriegebiet
atwater nimmt francesca den raum ein den
sie in der schweiz nie hatte ihren
rebellischen geist den sie in der genfer
hausbesetzerszene erprobt hat hat sie
behalten
ich gehörte zu den leuten die in genf
das ets gegründet haben und den etat die
chance also auch damals schon politische
ideen hatten
und auch wenn ich in einer gemeinschaft
gelebt hatte die sehr offen war musste
ich die wurzeln kappen um mich entfalten
zu können
[Musik]
ich glaube dass meine bilder immer schon
etwas von zerfallener architektur hatten
von notunterkunft von nest das zieht
sich wie ein roter faden durch meine
malerei
aber es stimmt auch dass sie mit
aktionen begannen und erst als ich
hierher gezogen bin wurde sie bildhafte
eine entwicklung die anerkannte galerien
wie hause und wird gerne begleiten
während sich die kunstwelt permanent
vorwärts bewegt sind die ideen der
regierenden regelmäßig rückwärtsgewandt
fersen und atmen auch mit 72 jahren
brennt d'or für das vermitteln und
weitergeben
die tänzerin und choreografin aus zürich
hat ihre spitzenschuhe auf allen großen
bühnen der welt geschmiert
sie hat an der ehrwürdigen metropolitan
opera in new york unterrichtet und
wechselte ohne zögern als community
college ein konservatorium das allen
offen steht
das ist keine harmonische bewegung das
ist wie auf der achterbahn und runter so
taucht ab ins tal und da gibt es diesen
moment hast du es schaffst du berührst
das universum
du hast all deine energie und dann dreht
probe und die habe ich jetzt
ich bin wahnsinnig stolz
bis 8
[Musik]
die songwriterin mit dem man befreundet
verdammt so fertig chancen zu mehr
spürst du das strikte ich berühre das
universum
was das im auge haben
[Musik]
lass los heute erteilt sie eine ihrer
allerletzten tanzstunden
denn dora wählen nach 40 jahren in den
vereinigten staaten in die schweiz
zurück heimweh kennt oder nicht ich habe
ja viel andere timna brauer spielfilme
not want 400 wand und es hat mir
eigentlich nie viel ausgemacht habe ich
etwas wiedergutmachung für mich da nicht
so viele muss jetzt wieder wie traurig
ich habe mich sauber das rechte der
mieter gar und nicht nur mit stecken
blieb und sich gute so was kann alles
lau
die zum luxus
foto weis das ist die längste park in
der längst die parkplatz auf der welt
eine schlimme nachricht wenn man vom
dienst gefährlich und bevor man zum
zentrum für welche unternehmen seine
kleinen engpass der schönen morgens
hatte ganztages
[Musik]
in los angeles ist autofahren die hölle
zu spitzenzeiten endet das roadmovie
eingekeilt in einer blechlawine
die wegzeiten richtig einzuplanen gehört
zu rosis stärken er fährt ungehindert in
den östlichen teil der stadt ein treuer
kunde hat ihn mit dem bau seines hauses
betraut
mit dieser kann man die bäume da nicht
stehen lassen eine wurde schon gefällt
doch zuerst brauchte eine baubewilligung
das ist das problem sie muss jetzt die
stadt ersetzen
sie werden es nicht tun wegen der kosten
ich muss schauen was anders geht ich
schaue mit den verantwortlichen ob wir
die dinge nicht anders herum machen
könnten was kompliziert ist roche stößt
an die grenzen des kalifornischen traum
station macht das leben überhaupt
aber heute taktisch ist einmal das ist
zwischen drei bis acht musiker die in
los angeles und wänden ein bisschen 23
yorker nachrichten checks nimmt er
seinen kampf gegen die städtische
bürokratie wieder auf
[Musik]
der verkehr schlängelt sich weiter ohne
unterbruch gut dass randy nerven aus
stahl hat und in bester begleitung ist
können wir uns seit juni 2002 seit 17
jahren
ich habe andy als fahrer
er gehört zur familie
wir gehen zusammen essen er lädt mich an
meinem geburtstag ein oder in silvester
zu sich nach hause
wir waren schon zusammen den konzerten
kurzum unsere beziehung ist
freundschaftlich nicht nur geschäftlich
wenn meine tochter nachts spät aus geht
wollen wir nicht dass sie einen ober
oder ein taxi nimmt
wir wollen dass randy sie abholt wenn
meine frau und ich zu einem konzert
gehen oder eine abendveranstaltung und
20.000 menschen sind dort dann können
wir aus und wissen dass randy genau beim
ausgang steht
manchmal sage ich wenn ich einen guten
fahrer begegnen dann erzähle ich dir ich
begegnete dem neuen die aus mexiko oder
den randy aus korea kommt gerade aus der
reinigung
[Musik]
die kehrseite der medaille ist für roche
dass er gegen den amtsschimmel ankommen
muss
cds angeles in weiß dass wir berliner
parlament wo man das meeting mit meiner
projekte zum lager dass wir alles hängt
für baubewilligung das allmählich in
downtown los angeles
viel stärker reguliert dass sie die
schweiz vor allem wenn es ums baumgart
das ist es ein vorteil ist dass man es
ist ja wahrscheinlich schon mich und
teils umgaben wahrlich organisiert ja
ich wahrscheinlich ein vorteil vor allem
der gut organisiert ist das
wahrscheinlich ein vorteil gelernt das
problem ist dass das meine schnitt hilft
wenn die anderen oder muss selber
schauen
ja menge sprit
das schlimmste woche passiert dann ist
das ein plan sorgen dass ich nicht aus
und wurde jetzt kontrollieren
ein schickes wieder auf in den
geheimnisvollen dschungel der
stadtverwaltung bekommt sie endlich die
lang ersehnte baubewilligung
[Musik]
ein campus der superlative
ein über 169 hektar großes grundstück in
weeze gut
knapp 45.000 studierende aus der ganzen
welt
die stadt in der stadt besteht aus 163
gebäuden
meist wird ein bekannter architekt mit
einem neubau betraut
florian geht die erste kurs woche zu
ende
es gibt 1000 neue sachen darin musst du
dich erst gewinnen aber alles in allem
läuft es gut ich muss mich beeilen sonst
komme ich zu spät
ich finde die kurse sehr gut sie sind
super interessant die professoren haben
eine art zu unterrichten die ich für
etwas amerikaner schallte es zu bauen
sind sie ein
sie bieten fast schon eine performance
seine show
hier das chinesische raumschiff das auf
dem mond gelandet ist
wie die chinesen haben auch die
vereinigten staaten ein
raumfahrtprogramm
die eu hat einst die russen auch damit
machen sie klar wir sind technisch doch
wir können das das ist ein starkes
zeichen und die chinesen haben ihre
leistungsfähigkeit der ganzen welt
vorgeführt
verwirkliche etwas im all und alle
werden es sehen und alle werden wissen
dass es alle gesehen haben
ein raumfahrtprogramm ist ein sehr
effizientes mittel auch die universität
kann prallen die namen der ehemaligen
lesen sich wie der abspann eines
hollywood klassikers francis ford
coppola jim morrisson james dean die
florian gerade mal ein semester ihr
verbracht haben
im san fernando valley 35 kilometer
außerhalb der stadt
doras zu hause in l -e heißt es das sei
randgebiet dabei werden ihr keiner autos
angezündet sondern gehegt und gepflegt
das haus wird wegen des anstehenden
verkaufs gerade aufgemöbelt hunde und
menschen sind in einem zimmer
zusammengepfercht und leiden unter den
bauarbeiten
das sind meine idee und mainz seien ihr
könnt ganz ruhig wir lassen euch nicht
zurück versprochen
er kommt mit uns in die schweiz
ihr wart ausgesetzte tiere die ich
aufgenommen haben ist alles wird gut das
verspreche ich euch
dass ich jetzt mal mit hochdruck sie in
der masse moment das parat macher zum
verkauf untersagt
das geht so haßmann pascual ist ein mann
des theaters
das paar arbeitet an einem film über die
tätowier kunst
das ist einmalig dass auch einmal das
ist japanisch
wunderschön in all dem chaos bewahren
haltung ganz disziplinierte tänzerin
pascal hat mit der vorstellung sein land
zu verlassen mehr mühe
auch gesundheitlich ist er nicht ganz
auf dem damm entspannen die schultern
beide ausatmen das wird ihr gut tun
ich liebe dich auch
und ich will nicht in los angeles alt
werden deshalb ist es gut zu gehen
nicht wahr mein schatz ich denke es wird
ein völlig neuer lebensplan und ein
neues leben alle 100 jahre ist gut für
dich weg von den politischen unruhen in
amerika solange wir noch können
keiner weiß was auf uns zukommt bist du
nicht ja sehr froh ich hoffe ich werde
ihm gerecht ich werde mich wohl
landessprache anpassen und so noch
besser lernen müssen
ich würde kurse an der migros klubschule
aber auch mit hubble auf dem handy
lernen
dank bei dem bericht an wohl prozent ja
sagen können
[Musik]
in dieser stadt brauchen kämpfer einen
langen atem haben rossi und sein
ingenieur deen den heiligen gral
gefunden poker gesichter und ein etwas
angestrengtes lächeln auf die
kleinigkeiten achten
sie wollen die pläne noch mal sehen
meine pläne sind gut wir haben es mit
verschiedenen städtischen abteilung wo
zu tun
einige nehmen es mit architektonischen
andere mit ingenieurs regeln sehr genau
einigen ist es komplett egal andere
wollen am liebsten gar nichts bauen
lassen
aber damit müssen wir leben
[Musik]
in los angeles regnet es nicht das weiß
jeder aber nach jahrelanger dürre wird
dem regen getanzt und gesungen
die wassertanks füllen sich und die
autos glänzten misst wir haben einen
umweg gemacht
das erinnerte mich an meine jugend
franziska muss eine stunde fahren um
ihre söhne milo & restore von der
internationalen schule abzuholen
europäischer lehrplan mit unterricht auf
englisch und französisch um das niveau
zu halten
doch wie geht es dann in füssen sind sie
nass brauchst du ein anderes paar schuhe
müssen wir dir für heute abend neue
schuhe kaufen
[Musik]
letzter stopp des tages für randy bei
seiner firma wo er seine limousine
abstellt
der betrieb ist auf dienstleistungen für
wie ip spezialisiert
markus ich bin fertig bis morgen
[Musik]
ich bin ständig unterwegs die an den
strand ich arbeite bin sehr aktiv
schlafen kann ich wenn ich tot bin
[Musik]
in den hügeln von los feliz bei
hollywood in der nähe des größten
wassertanks der stadt selber league das
viertel ist ein wahrer künstler pole
hier wohnt francesca mit ihrer familie
nehmt die papiere mit jungs
sonst
ich habe drei hündinnen 3
ich brauche hier weibliche energie um
mich herum habe ich nur macker ich habe
einen mann und zwei söhne
es riecht nach käse füßen unter
klodeckel ist ständig deshalb brauche
ich weibliche energie von meinen hunden
das sind fotos die kopie von meinen
kindern gemacht hat im gegenzug bekam
sie ein bild wir haben getauscht
sie möchte sie noch mal fotografieren
das wäre super jetzt wo sie teenager
sind und das ist ein bild von edis vater
er war ein großartiger mann und das ist
ein foto von seinem vater und der
schwiegervater mein bekannter pop art
künstler der ehemann und kinder musiker
ganz einfach eine kreative familie
ich mache heute abend bürger vor ganz
genau dass schweizer rezept für bürger
ich denke wir sollten zuerst das gemüse
machen was meine kunst angeht konnte ich
als ich noch keine kinder hatte in
meinem atelier
auch bis mitternacht ich konnte arbeiten
das ging problemlos
aber jetzt geht es nicht mehr deshalb
müssen wir uns etwas besser organisieren
damit beides klappt gleichzeitig sollte
keines von beidem leiden weil die kinder
die ich brauche
wir versuchen die dinge gut zu machen so
wie wir es für richtig halten und
trotzdem unsere identität als künstler
zu bewahren
es kann dazu führen dass du deine kunst
anders fokussiert ich glaube es war ein
vielen dingen sogar hilfreich kinder zu
haben und dadurch eine breitere
perspektive auf das leben auf unserem
platz in der welt
effektive tatsächlich bietet kalifornien
für mich eine art freiheit sogar für den
eigenen lebensstil für die art wie du
lebst die art einen offeneren blick auf
die dinge zu haben ich wurde in der
schweiz und das war gut aber es war
anders
es war ein wenig ein restaurant dort die
bürgerin würde
[Musik]
die prüfung hat drei teile redet ihr
über marx mx wahrscheinlich und sicher
von martin luther king junior die
schwarzen panther ich habe einen
wunderbaren film von annes vater gesehen
ja den hast du mir gezeigt
wir sollten uns wurde abend anschauen
sie war so jung und so klein aber sie
hat die schwarzen panther gefühl
fernab von hollywood glamour league
north hollywood ein bescheidenes viertel
in dem die straßenlaternen die spotlight
sind
[Musik]
los angeles ist eine riesige stadt nicht
wie lugano wo ich aufgewachsen bin mit
meinem umfeld meinen freunden den
nachbarn
ich fühle mich hier nicht allein
es ist kein problem das ich ledig bin
dass ich keine familie haben weil ich
ständig unter leuten werden
[Musik]
wenn ich zu hause bin oder hier mag ich
die nähe zu den tieren die ich liebe ich
liebe das leben weil ich tun und lassen
kann was ich will
[Musik]
manchmal da gab es so momente im laufe
des jahres zu weihnachten oder neujahr
ich hatte niemanden wusste nicht wohin
und lieber allein zu hause es gab
momente der einsamkeit in dieser großen
stadt
[Musik]
in der stadt der 1000 lichter lauert die
einsamkeit im schatten
sie wittert ihre beute bereit sie zu
verschlingen
wer in allen überleben will muss die
einsamkeit besiegen
[Musik]
man sieht die häuser in flammen und vor
allem die enorme muss er auch die über
die stadt kommt wie kann ich das
darstellen
wie sieht offiziell verspätete 550 wenn
wir das erreichen wollen brauchen wir
eine strategie
[Musik]
ok
schwitzen in los angeles präsentiert
wurde forces stück heimat wo sie sind
[Musik]